90 MINUTES FROM NOW.
>> Sandra: WE WILL BE WATCHING
FOR THAT.
>> Ed: STATE LEADERS ORDERING
POLLS CLOSE JUST HOURS BEFORE
PRIMARY VOTING WAS SET TO BEGIN
THERE.
MAKING THAT CONTROVERSIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT AFTER A JUDGE AND
INITIALLY DENIED HIS REQUEST FOR
THE ELECTION TO BE POSTPONED
OVER CORONAVIRUS CONCERNS.
>> YOU SHOULD NOT FORCE THEM TO
MAKE THIS CHOICE.
A CHOICE BETWEEN THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT -- RIGHTS.
AS AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> Ed: ELLISON BARBER IS LIVE
IN COLUMBUS, OHIO, WITH THE
LATEST.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
TO SAY THAT THINGS HAVE BEEN
CONFUSING HERE IN THE LAST
24 HOURS OR SO IS A BIT OF AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
SOME PEOPLE ACTUALLY TRY TO SHOW
UP TO THE VARIOUS LOCATIONS
THINKING THAT THEY COULD VOTE,
ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT IT WAS NOT
HAPPENING TODAY.
THEY WERE GREETED BY SIGNS ON
THE DOOR, SAYING THAT IT HAS
BEEN POSTPONED.
MIKE DeWINE SENDS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OHIO
VOTERS.
THEY NEEDED TO POSTPONE IN
PERSON VOTERS.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO MAKE THAT CHANGE,
SO THEY FILED A LAWSUIT TO
EXTEND ABSENT EMAIL AND VOTING
UNTIL JUNE 2ND.
BUT A JUDGE IN FRANKLIN COUNTY
DENIED THAT REQUEST AND A DEEMED
VOTING WAS BACK ON.
THEN GOVERNOR DeWINE ANNOUNCED
THAT THE ELECTION WOULD NOT
HAPPEN, AND OHIO’S HEALTH
DIRECTOR, DATE DOMINIC DR. AMY
ATKINS ORDERED THE POLLS CLOSE.
"WE WILL SEEK REMEDY THROUGH THE
COURTS TO EXTEND VOTING OPTIONS
SO THAT EVERY VOTER WHO WANTS TO
VOTE WILL BE GRANTED THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
WE JUST SPOKE TO THAT MAN.
HE TOLD US THAT HE IS NOW
PREPARING FOR LEGAL CHALLENGES.
BUT HE SAYS HE IS CONFIDENT THAT
THAT DECISIONS MADE IN THIS
STATE ARE LEGAL, AND HE SAYS
THEY ACTED AS QUICKLY AND
DECISIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
>> I’M CONFIDENT THAT WE MAY
HAVE THE RIGHT CHOICE AND THE
LEGALLY CORRECT CHOICE AS WELL.
I DON’T THINK THAT ANY OF US WHO
SERVE IN POSITIONS OF
RESPONSIBILITY CAN NEVER LOOK
BACK AND SAY WE DID EVERYTHING
100% PERFECTLY.
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT
GOVERNOR DeWINE ACTED TO
PROTECT HEALTH AND SAFETY FEARED
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT I
IMMEDIATELY RESPONDED TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS,
AND THE CONFIDENCE PEOPLE HAVE
IN OUR ELECTIONS, AND OTHER
GOVERNOR STANDS BY HIS DECISION.
I STAND BY MIND.
>> THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS NOW
URGING VOTERS TO GO ONLINE TO
VOTE.